اعلنت واشنطن فرد عقوبات تستهدف شخصيات من
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
ومؤسسات وشركات تابعه او داعمه او متعامله
معهما كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما رساله واشنطن الى طرفي
الصراع في السودان من خلال العقوبات اي
تاثيرات مباشره للعقوبات خصوصا في المجال
العسكري وكيف نفهم دلاله الاعلان عن تعليق
المحادثات بين طرفي الصراع من قبل رعاته
نعلم ان هذه العقوبات توليه خاصه انها
تهدف فيما تهدف الى تعديل سلوك الاضرار
ونجحت في ذلك قد تكون اكثر اهميه لو كانت
هنالك اطراف اخرى اخرى تفاعلت مع الشركات
السودانيه المرتبطه مع القوات السودانيه
والقوات الدعم السريع لربما ايضا اخذت هذه
العقوبات بجديه ومثلا اوقفت المواد الخام
واجزاء التي او المعدات واي معدات اخرى
تحتاجها تلك الشركات من اجل الاستمرار
بالعمل
في الحفاظ على ارواح المواطنين وممتلكاتهم
فكان بالاولى ان تختصر هذه العقوبات على
الطرف الذي نرى ونسمع ونشاهد انتهاكات
الكبيره اذا كان من انتهاكات قليله بسبب
صدر الهجمات التي يقوم بها الدعم السريع
فكان الاولى ان تعتبر جزء من حاله الدفاع
قبل سنتين تقريبا كان هنالك عقوبات اهم تم
فرضها على السودان 700 مليون دولار من
المساعدات الامريكيه تم تجميدها 6 مليارات
دولار مساعدات من البنك الدولي وصندوق
النقد الدولي تم تجميدها وبدعم الولايات
المتحده وخمسين مليار دولار من غاثه
الديون تم ايقافها هذه من الواضح لم تقنع
اطراف المتصارعه في وقتها في ان تنهي
الصراع العقوبات ضد اربع شركات سودانيه
مرتبطه بالجيش السوداني ومرتبطه بقواته
الدعم السريع وتلك الشركات لا تمتلك روابط
قويه مع الولايات المتحده الروابط هي اكبر
مع دول اخرى مثل روسيا والامارات العربيه
المتحده بالتالي ليس من المحتمل ان يكون
لهذه العقوبات تاثير كبير
في هذا الاطار تحجم من الجيش وتجعل من
فاعليه شركات وممارساتهم امرا يعني مشكوك
فيه اما فيما يخص الدعم السريع فان
التاثير لطبع سيكون اقل انه لا يتعامل
حاليا مع الدوله وليس لديه علاقات خارجيه
ولا ولا يدعى لذلك الجيش السوداني لديه
تجربه طويله مع الحصار ومع منع استمرار
الصناعات العسكريه واستجابه من الخارج
تمكن في ختامها ان يصنع الادوات والوسائل
العسكريه والاسلحه داخل السودان قول
المستشار السياسي لقوات الدعم السريع لانه
لم يؤثر عليه هذا هذا هراء لان الدعم
السريع عقيدتها القتاليه الاتي تشتغل بها
الان
ومنذ تاسيسها وحتى الان تقوم على المال
تقوم على المصالح الماليه تقوم على
العلاقات الماليه تقوم على بيع الذهب تقوم
على نهج اموال المواطنين
قرر ان يتراجع وينسحب من المحادثات في
الوقت الحالي ولم يكن هنالك اي امكانيه
للمضي قدما من هذا لا يعني انها انتهت
بامكان ان يتم اعاده هذه المفاوضات اذا ما
رغب الطرفان بالعوده اليها لذلك الان لا
هدنه والالتزام والبسيطين يعني
محاولاتهما فان الجيش السوداني الذي كان
يحاول ان يحافظ بقدر الامكان على على
المواقع السكنيه الان يحاول ان يدخل بحرصه
على الحيوانات الاخرين وعلى المرافق
المدنيه ان يدخل في هذه المعركه بالقوه
التي تؤهله لطرد العدوان ولتحجيم قوات
الدعم السريع ليس هناك تغيير كبير سيحدث
كانت جيش يقول بانه دمر كل المعسكرات لكن
يتضح الان ان هناك معسكرات ما يزال الدعم
السريع محتفظ بها بل زاد من من نفوذه في
معسكرات اخرى كانت تتبع للجيش الدعم
السريع وجيش عليهم ان يتخذوا القرار على
انهم من مصلحه الشعب السوداني ان يكون
هنالك وقف اطلاق النار اي قوه خارجيه لا
يمكنها ان تجبر اطراف الصراع على القيام
بذلك